we're going to begin with the breaking
news from Israel with the deepening
turmoil there over prime minister
Benjamin netanyahu's move to limit the
independence of the country's Supreme
Court weeks and weeks of protests have
led to this you're looking at the scene
outside the Israeli legislature that's
the knesset in Jerusalem and a new wave
of protest erupted yesterday after the
defense minister there was fired for
calling for a delay in this plan until
after Easter and Passover this morning
labor unions called for a general strike
and the protest may have actually forced
Netanyahu and his right-wing government
to reconsider or at least consider a
pause Charlie dagada is following this
story from London Charlie good morning
good morning to you Tony Israel is
bracing for further protests today and
the prime minister is facing the
greatest threat yet to his coalition
government there are now reports that
you mentioned he may halt that overhaul
following a long night of Nationwide
demonstrations
[Applause]
organizers called for a night of chaos
and demonstrators by the tens of
thousands delivered
protesters poured onto the streets in
Tel Aviv
[Applause]
taking over the main Highway shouting
Israel is not a dictatorship
blowing air horns blocking traffic and
burning tires Riot police deployed water
cannon drenching the crowds it's not a
matter of left or right it's a matter of
pure basic human rights that are being
crushed daily
protests also broke out in Jerusalem
around the Israeli legislative building
and outside the home of prime minister
Benjamin Netanyahu
shouting Shane Shane
the eruption came on the back of
netanyahu's firing of his defense
minister for breaking ranks with the
prime minister's hard-line policies
the growing Rift in our society is
penetrating the Israeli Defense Force
and security agencies said yo of Gallant
it poses a clear immediate and tangible
threat to the security of the state
critics have come down hard on
netanyahu's highly controversial plans
to overhaul the judicial system the
proposals would see government control
over the appointment of Judges including
the Supreme Court while restricting the
Court's rights to veto legislation or
rule against the government
get out that's been met with weeks of
anti-government protests and Nationwide
strikes
unions have gone on strike shutting down
the universities and grounding flights
out of Israel's main airport another
Mass demonstration has been called for
this afternoon outside of parliament
Tony
and of course if that legislation to
overhaul the courts does pass who gets
to look at it the courts they could veto
it causing an even deeper deepen our
crisis Charlie thank you very much